he commits all of these sins on a daily
basis but he prays is better in the eyes
of Allah than the one that doesn't
commit any of these sins but doesn't
pray If Heaven or God truly operate this
way send me to hell this is a message in
sh to clarify things now he did not
say the main goal of a mentor is to pass
on the energy of a
[Music]
win those chosen by a mentor have the
capability to harness this energy Gilla
power for your greatest
fight brothers and sisters and dear
friends so basically there's this video
going viral on um two YouTubers uh their
names Abba and preach um so they've
reacting to a video of Muhammad hoblos a
short clip that's been going quite viral
a lot of people obviously did not
understand what he meant I'm going to
clarify that in and I don't totally
blame these individuals I don't think
they come from hostile place it's their
first impressions of Islam maybe and
it's like well it's too much to take
and this the reason why Ali he's a
companion of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said do not tell the people
what they are not ready to hear do you
want them to disbelieve in God and His
messenger so that's what I'm going to
bring context to that let's get straight
into in of the reaction video I think
there's five key points they mentioned
and I'm going to break down what Islam
really preaches and what it really says
in so here we go this is the first clip
inah badad how about the murer how about
the one who commits adultery iner what
about the one who a child what about the
one who drinks alcohol bed this person
one person that commits all of these
sins he commits all of these sins on a
daily basis but he prays is better in
the eyes of Allah than the one that
doesn't Comm me any of these sins but
doesn't
pray no I'm not going to talk [__] about
religion
uh my God the logic of religions it is
what it is you believe in what you want
to believe in that's good uh I just
don't adhere to it that's what I'm going
to say I'm not going to go further but
yeah that's just not me you you and
that's on top of that that's the
interpretation of one person of religion
you know what I mean so that changes to
pretty extreme whatever this is alone
bike logic if you pray for a bike you'll
never get it but if you steal a bike and
ask for forgiveness it's morally
okay the fact that his sentences even
included drinking alcohol and like it's
the same thing like you just sto a you
already know this man's Twisted oh yeah
he put them shits in the same merking
people and drinking alcohol same
thing absolutely not [__] out of here
listen to a man that tell me gra and a
kid is going to be somewhat decent as
long as you pray this is a message in to
clarify things now he did not say that
it's very important yeah because there
there's kind of a bit of a um twist
happening here which unintentional he
did not say that doing those things are
okay as long as you pray he's not saying
that he's trying to say basically he's
trying to give the importance of who God
is and not worshiping him is the biggest
form of sin in Islam we have many major
Sins murder grape of a child whoever for
that matter any woman for that matter uh
stealing adultery um alcohol there's
many other things that constitute as a
major sin he's trying to show the
greatest the worstest examples to make
that seem that this is more severe than
that so for example just because he said
that for example doing a b c d d e FG
whatever it is for that matter he's
given those analogies and those examples
to show you the severity of what that
means now I wouldn't personally give
those examples because it is difficult
for people to comprehend you can truly
understand that when you have a
relationship with God and know who God
is because that's our Point as Muslims
we believe God Almighty deserves worship
because of who he is not because of what
he does for us all the blessings that we
have in our life so for example if I
come and say to give an example of how
bad it is to um argument sake um rape or
grape a child yeah let's put or like
abuse sexually abuse a child then I give
an example and say you know if you went
and murdered somebody or murdered your
mom raped your mom killed your mom burnt
your mom then went and did the same to
your brother and your sister and this
that that is not worse as doing it to a
child this does not mean that for
example they are it's better it's better
for you to do this but just don't do
that no is to show the severity of how
bad this is that's the point and of
course it's a gruesome example but this
does not mean or equate that he meant
that yeah you can do that stuff no
because in Islam it's very clear that
there's God's rights and there's human
beings rights that's why many of the
companions or many of the Sal would say
that we would rather stand in front of
God with 70 sins between us and God a
violation against God rather than one
sin that we have violated and wronged
somebody's rights in Islam the rights of
an individual very very severe so many
so much so that the prophet Muhammad
peace be him refused funeral prayer on
an individual who didn't pay his debt to
somebody so we know that on the day of
judgment a person who has violated the
rights of somebody else will not go into
Paradise until they've sorted that issue
out so it's not just a matter of oh if
you just pray and do all of the things
it's okay it could come across like that
but that's not what he is saying he's
saying that to not worship God is far
severe than anything you can do any kind
of evil I would a person say any evil
that you can think not praying to God is
far worse why because of who God is now
for example when it comes to morality
imagine for example for us to understand
this concept you can think why is just
not worshiping imagine we had aliens and
aliens have different morality from a
different planet they came to us and for
them arguments sorry for the bad
examples maybe but for them um imagine
alien says for us to um I don't know
spit in the face of another fellow alien
is far worse yes and this and and the
way they can comprehend that how can we
make them make how can they make us
understand their morality they would
come to us and say okay you know for you
guys what is the worst thing in your
moral view in your planet oh in our
planet for example raping a child
killing them is far worse they like okay
so you see that thing that you guys do
it's as good as spitting out my friend's
face imagine an alien
just a random example that is equivalent
to that now we can't come and say what
how could you that's their morality
according to their Planet yeah okay I'm
just giving an example that is their
morality they're trying to give us an
example not saying that is okay for you
to do as long as you not they're saying
that is bad or worse than that because
to our morality so that's what we're
seeing in the sight of God Almighty to
not worship Him is far worse than any
sins that we can do that's where it's
coming from nowhere in Islam does it
tell us that you can go and do that to
individuals the right of it in Islam is
far far greater so I just want to make
that clear now let's move on to some
other points that they made a lot of
people view the relationship with
religion as long as you just show up to
church of it absolves you and and right
back on Monday or whenever the hell you
go back you go back right back to your
[__] yeah this makes me think of
people who are like you know family over
everything like the [__] is a
murderer yeah but he's your brother I'm
like I don't care he went up and killed
five people he got to go this makes me
think of that it's just this kind of
blind loyalty this thing doesn't matter
how evil how repent this is the right
thing to do listen I don't get this
mindset I never did even as a young kid
it just felt like close your eyes and
follow the rules cuz we know better even
if it flew in the face of every value I
thought was
important so the second point that they
made for example that Muslims or
religious people Christians where for
that matter just as long as you go to
the church you pray go out and do evil
no of course not we are told that we are
abstain from these sins as Muslims we
need to be up upholders of righteousness
that's why Allah tell us in the Quran
that speak the truth even if it's
against yourself so you talked about you
know knowing a family member doing this
no Allah tells us in the Quran that we
have to speak the truth even if it is
against our kin my own blood brother
sister mother daughter wife whoever if
they are wrong we tell them that's wrong
there's no oh it's religious no no no no
no he's wrong he's wrong I don't care if
he's a Muslim I don't care who he is I
don't care if it's an IM he's wrong
we'll tell him he's wrong so that's a
big misconception please do not put us
into the same category of Christians or
this might not even be a Christian issue
I'll be honest with you I don't think
there's anything Christianity that say
says that so I have to defend them again
look look you know I have to defend
Christianity even though I believe it's
falsehood but I have to defend it
because I don't think there's anything
scripture in the Bible that tells you to
hide as as long as far as I know next uh
point If Heaven or God truly operate
this way send me to
hell if you could truly go by your day
and force yourself on children and as
long as you pray five times you're doing
good I don't want to be send me to
help I say this very earnestly there is
never a time in my life where I ever
wanted to feel like prayer is some kind
of get out of jail free card okay
another misconception that prayer is a
get out of jail free card in Islam We
Believe even Muslims will end up in
Hellfire why because every person is
going to be accountable there might be a
Muslim who prays his prayer who fasts in
Ramadan who gives in charity who goes to
pilgrimage who does all of these Good
Deeds Etc but if he has violated
people's rights we have clear
description that there's punishment in
the grave there's question on the day of
judgment and there will be some Muslims
who will end up in the Hellfire a lot of
them why because of the sins they
committed for the people that they
wronged so there is no get out of jail
free card you're not going to stand in
front of God and violated somebody's
rights like I said to you before a sin
down against God God can choose to
forgive cuz God is the one that is being
wrong they in that sense but when you
wrong and violate the rights of a
individual you will be taken to account
so that's the reason why BR my dear my
friend Abba and preach that there is no
get free card will a Muslim eventually
enter Paradise after he's done time in
Hellfire yes but we don't have this
concept of you know Christianity which
we're going to come to a bit later so
just want to make that very clear that
there is no I am praying I'm going to
Paradise no you will get the punishment
because if your sins are greater than
your good deeds so let's make that yeah
another misconception questioning when I
was a kid you mean I just as long as I
just accept Jesus Christ as my Lord and
Savior everything is just forget God
yeah what if I suddenly die in a car
accident and no you're not going to end
what if I'm a freaking baby like I'm a
baby I didn't get time to understand
what it and I die don't get it no what
then this [__] is unfair I thought it
was supposed to be fair and just it's
not oh another point that I think his
name is AB I don't know which one's AB I
don't know which one's preach okay
they're both preaching so the thing is
here that a point that you made is this
is in Christianity that if you what
about all the other people you're right
all those other people millions of years
ago who did not know about Jesus dying
for your sins CU there was no concept
like that we don't believe this is from
Christianity so are they going to go
help that's exactly my point that's a
very valid point in Islam we believe
that anybody that hasn't reached the age
of puberty who is not mentally stable
okay who hasn't heard the message of
Islam or some Scholars even say heard
the message of Islam but in a wrong way
will not go hell but rather will be
tested on the day of judgment with a
special test why because God is just how
is it fair why would he throw you in
Hellfire when you didn't hear the the
message so just to be clear nowhere in
Islam does it teach you that um you know
if you didn't hear it uh you're just
going to hear that's Christianity not in
Islam in Islam you are not accountable
until you you are sane and you can make
decisions for yourself so I think that's
in a nutshell the points that I wanted
to react to and I just want to again
like I said before it's a big
misconception to I understand it's not
your fault guys you know this maybe the
first time you've come across it but
believe me this person Muhammad H I know
him personally I know what kind of a
person he is he was trying to show the
severity of how great of a sin it is to
not worship God those examples did not
need to be given I'm sure he
acknowledges that because not everyone
can grasp and truly understand it but I
want you guys to know in Islam there are
three conditions when you do a sin you
stop the sin you try not to go back to
it and you hate the sin and that means
when you repent to it your Deeds get
forgiven uh whatever You' done if you
stopped it and it will turn into Good
Deeds the fourth condition is if you
have wronged somebody if you have stolen
from someone if you have backbitten
someone if you have wronged someone you
have to go and ask for their forgiveness
very vital Islam gives such great imput
uh uh emphasis on the rights of a human
being it's I I don't think there's any
religion that emphasize on that so once
again just to clarify he is not given
those examples to belittle the others
yes he's basically trying to say that
not worshiping God is far worser than
anything you can imagine this does not
mean that a Muslim can go and do those
things or it does not mean that if
somebody goes and does these things and
thinks who are you fooling you think you
can fool God by like oh yeah I'm going
to go go and do a b and c and I'm just
going to pray to God who do you think
you're fooling God knows your inner
intentions that's why in Islam Every
Good Deed is based on its intention so I
just wanted to clarify that and one
thing I want to say to you guys which uh
maybe this might uh make you understand
if I was good to everybody and I went
home let's suppose I'm good to anybody
everybody I give charity to everyone
everyone would know me as what a good
person a righteous person how about if I
went home and beat my mom up I punched
her in the face and I was abusing her am
I good or bad everyone will say I'm a
bad person but I thought I'm good to
everyone so the point is that if you are
violating the rights of God Almighty it
doesn't matter how good you are to other
people the point is that it starts with
God Almighty he's the one that sustains
you looks after you gives you all these
blessings and I don't know if you guys
are religious or not I'm assuming you
guys are not religious atheist then this
goes back to the argument of morality
where do you get immorality from because
there's a lots of things in atheism
which we can come and say hold on a
second where did you get that moral
compass from to even say argument say
this is right or this is wrong it comes
from his subjective morality subjetive
morality from your mind yes so we say
objective morality true morality comes
from God Almighty uh cuz otherwise
according to atheism there are many
things we can come and say okay how is
that wrong incest how is that wrong
homosexuality how is that wrong
necrophilia having intimacy with the
dead corpse how is that wrong according
to atheism so I think there's something
we can talk about maybe abam preach I
mean we can have a podcast I don't it's
up to you guys I'm open to tell you guys
more about Islam and it was a total
misunderstanding hope that clarifies for
you that's all I wanted to say and again
like I said guys it's I'm not blaming
them because they this the first
impression they don't come from a
hostile place and let's just keep it
like that let's not you know b or call
them names I don't think there's nothing
to be called there was a
misunderstanding this clarifies and
maybe you can react to this thank you
very much guys till next time